so we were thinking
all right it's hot damn right it's hard
you're asking for somebody's kid Usman
blindsides his brother Muhammad by
asking to adopt his four-year-old son
mahadi this comes after Usman and Kim
were made aware that polygamy in the U.S
is illegal that is a well-known fact so
if he wants to marry Kim and move to
America he can't have a second wife to
give him children
I was thinking if you can give us Madi
to adopt him as our child
wondering if mahadi's mom was going to
have a say in this you know look at him
she couldn't help but cringe I feel like
this was just going too far I have so
many thoughts let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia some of
y'all are so sweet I appreciate all the
love and support you show I know we
don't know each other but in my head
we're friends so Hi friend before we get
into Usman trying to take this little
cutie quick update on Jenny and submit
you know things were going well for them
for a minute they had us laughing as we
watched their new adventures we could
draw the cowgirl Cowboy one yeah
and they were being romantic in their
own awkward way I plan on attacking him
should I probably jump on top of him you
know and ride him like a pony
a pony yeah but thank you
well now the drama is back the drama we
are used to between them and you already
know it includes the midst parents last
week he Ginny and Jenny's daughters who
are visiting India met up with submit's
dad and brother his mom didn't show up
because she's still ashamed of the fact
that he married Jenny who is 30 years
older than him he also said they accept
all the religions
[Music]
the conversation got off to a bad start
and Contin
uesome its family that they're
considering moving to the U.S which took
submit by surprise
I don't want to take him away from his
family
but I think maybe it's better if we just
go ahead and live in America then
and then we won't maybe we won't be
upsetting the family so much we he I
won't be we won't be seen together I
guess so fast forward to this week's
episode submit said oh Jenny wants to
randomly tell my family that we plan to
move to America which is something that
I did not agree to well I'm about to
drop a bomb on her and her family I will
be 35 by two years
and maybe I'll start thinking about uh
having kids
we might adopt someone
by 35
then I want to have them in India
what
what no first of all we've talked about
this since we met over 10 years ago that
this can't happen it has been understood
this whole entire time so how come all
of a sudden now he wants to have a kid
when it was never
I mean I'm shocked submit looks scared
he goes on to tell Jenny this whole
kid's situation came up because he
thinks that it's a way he can win his
family's love back once again Smith will
do anything to make his parents happy it
doesn't seem like anything has changed
family is going to be priority basically
we always over me well Jenny he married
you without his parents permission so I
don't see it as him prioritizing his
family over you he just wants to have
you and his parents in his life
which honestly I don't blame him
this situation is just stressful to
think about so let's go ahead and move
on all right time to get into the moment
we've been waiting for with Kim Usman
and little mahadi first let's take a
look at Jamal's somewhat tense
conversation with Usman that took place
the night before they are set to meet up
with usman's brother Muhammad this
conversation is a result of Usman
revealing at the last minute that his
brother knows nothing about the plans
he's making to adopt his son earlier
today I got to see Eastman in a
different light
you kind of dropped a huge bomb with my
mom and you know it's very concerning to
me
it seems like a pattern where he kind of
tells the truth that will make him look
good versus telling all the fine details
I'm upset with them too you know I feel
like he really should have sort of the
truth you know y'all are getting kind of
ahead of yourselves with this child
thing and it's like you've kind of been
on vacation mode this whole time don't
you think it might be a good idea to
make sure y'all can even live together
first before bringing a child into
y'all's lives that's a good point have
they spent more than a month and a half
together Elizabeth says quote
fascinating Jamal is the parent and Kim
is the child
Elizabeth
hey that tends to be the reality for a
lot of parents and children sometimes as
children grow older they end up having
strengths where their parents are weak
it happens
although it is unfortunate if a child
has to step in and take on that role at
a very young age but that is another
conversation it is way too deep for
right now if that child was you though
I send you my love seriously you're
strong all right back to Jamal telling
Usman about himself I think about future
how we can live together
how our life going to be you know
there's going to be sweet for both of us
that's not the reality right now I know
the reality is you gave her a decision
of adopting your brother's son and I
feel like this is kind of another
sacrifice she's making for you sometimes
I feel like you don't really realize how
much my mom does for you
you know like I'm not saying you don't
appreciate it but right now it kind of
seems like you think you do a lot more
than her well really I think it's kind
of like even I still don't think it's
even but maybe Jamal knows more than I
do I think that Usman thinks the major
sacrifice he's making here is the mere
fact that he's with Kim considering her
age y'all remember when he said this I
compromise more than you
I think I have done what I have never
done in my life
saying that after I tell the whole world
that I'm not going to be with any other
lady and here I am
still can't get past the fact that he
caught his woman an old lady
very rude she's 52. she's older than you
but she's not an old lady
I'm only looking out for her and she
wants to be with you and she's always
going to have my support you know but if
I feel like you're I'm always gonna have
her back
[Music]
someone has to be there for it you know
what I'm saying someone else to be there
yeah but I don't think in Kimball and
our relationship doesn't it believe me
what I don't think any of us believe you
Usman
Kim has cried real unhappy tears in this
relationship it wasn't too long ago when
you basically called her ugly I have
like a bunch of drugs beautiful out of
60 women around me I'm rejecting it
because I feel like it shouldn't be Duty
or whatever you should be loved somebody
ugly in the heart and she has to pick
herself back up from that also why would
you tell a son not to be there for his
mother that statement in itself is a red
flag
it's actually kind of scary
someone else to be there yeah but I
don't think in Kimball and our
relationship there's no need believe me
[Music]
those intense
are giving me Scar and Mufasa Vibes
let's take a look at that one more time
believe me
[Music]
um I don't like that us man those vibes
are way off
sometimes I think Jamal gets too much
into his mom's business and it is too
much for me and after we meet Muhammad a
person I think Kimberly will be okay
with the adoption and no matter what
your mom see Kimberly just have to
accept it if we are going to be together
forever that's the only way we can move
forward you know
I'll be here I'm not going nowhere
period
let him know bro you just came in the
picture
one thing if Jamal was overstepping but
I don't think he is he has been giving
Sound Advice that is in Kim's best
interest to hear but I don't have to say
that
y'all know
all right it's the next day and it's
time for Kim Jamal and Usman to meet up
with usman's brother wife and son is
there another mirror you can go get
ready in I should have used this one I
mean I'm using it
why are you mad at me I don't know we're
about to go meet your brother and his
wife and tell him this white lady he's
from America is coming to kidnap their
baby because somebody didn't tell them
not very happy about that still once I
get to the park they have a cute little
meet and greet with usman's family
[Music]
hottie the little boy a gift I told you
she is good with the gifts little does
he know though she is alluring him in
how are you brother good this is Jamal
nice to meet you my son
his name is
I have met mahadi before but I haven't
spent time with mahadi because he lives
in sokoto with Muhammad and I've only
been to Silk Hotel a couple times
mahadi is so smart and he's just an
amazing kid but at the same time I never
thought I would consider adoption at
this stage in my life and right now I'm
terrified to hear what mahadi's parents
are going to think about all of this
OMG he's adorable such a sweet face I
would want to take him too
I'm just kidding
ah
they sit down and while there's a bit of
awkward silence at first usman's brother
Muhammad finally comes out and says okay
what's up why did you invite us here
um
okay
I don't feel like I need another wife
because getting two wives it may deny me
to move to America
because it's not legal over there for
those of you who are confused about the
other TLC show Mr wives
Cody the
quote spiritually married to his other
wives
just FYI so we were thinking
it's hard right it's hot spit it out I
was thinking if you can give us my ID
to adopt him as our child
me
okay
don't worry like we are going to take
care of him 100.
give you money as hell I don't
understand like what I'm saying is that
she's going to be like legally our son
under our chair
I swear if I move to the state you know
you have to move with me
ah
do y'all have memories from childhood
days that you thought were good days you
might have been hanging out with your
cousins your friends or you got taken
out of school early just you thought it
was a fun day but come to find out
when you got older you learned that that
day was not as peachy as you thought and
you were actually in the middle of some
drama
am I the only one that has definitely
happened to me before
I say that to say I wonder what mahadi's
reaction is going to be when he's older
and he looks back on this footage and
sees that Uncle Usman was trying to take
him so he could live with his fiance in
America
Jamal is looking like what has my mom
gotten us into
oh yeah it's awkward and in my opinion
it's a little disrespectful too they're
being put on the spot about their child
on camera
we can take care of him
I'll make sure that he has the best
education in this life basically we can
give him all whatever he needs
these are not just materialistic let's
remember that we'll provide
Mahari is so cute he reminds me a little
bit of Jamal when Jamal was like that
age and part of me does have this
feeling and like I could raise this
child but at the same time mahaja's
parents are looking at me they think I'm
crazy and they never expected that I
wanted to adopt mahadi not just to adopt
the baby I'm uprooting this child from
his culture right it's not like he's a
baby baby he's four this could
potentially be traumatic for him what do
y'all think do you think America being
the land of opportunity makes it worth
the risk
let me know mahari's mom goes on to tell
Kim and Usman she has to think about it
which I did not expect but I am glad
that her opinion is being considered
because to be honest I just didn't know
if it would
this is
very powerful
I don't want a situation whereby my
child will go there
without having Islamic orientation
um
yeah
foreign
yes and her response yeah I'm not doing
that absolutely not
funny
there must be certain conditions
I'm not going to come
but I'm just not you know
that he needed to talk to them before I
got here no is we are still talking
but you're surprised even if you're not
surprised them with this it's just not
cool to me
I think the best idea is let's go and
think about this
so they want him to be raised Muslim and
I'm not Muslim and if you're not there
all the time then what yeah you can't
just let us make all the decisions y'all
sure y'all still want to think about
this Muhammad and wifey and one thing I
thought about is usman's Mom going to
accept this I thought she wanted Usman
to have a child of his own mahadi is
already her grandchild
I got the gist that she wanted another
one it is very clear that Muhammad does
have a lot of reservations about me
raising mahadi to be Muslim
and I don't want to convert to Muslim
I've given so much in this relationship
I've sacrificed a lot already and I feel
like this was just going too far
fast forward to later on that night Kim
is stressing so she and Jamal take a
walk to have a real talk
like that's not realistic to me you need
to spend more time with mahadi you know
this isn't going to be overnight I would
make more trips here it's not going to
happen like I'm not going to go home
after this and take him home with me and
start filing the paperwork me and who's
been starting to get married you don't
know what Houston's gonna do because he
keeps talking about the back and forth
between here in Nigeria I mean I would
just have to deal with it you know what
I mean
I mean these are things you need to
think about before you keep saying like
oh I would do it well when I hear
Reasons from you that are like actually
makes sense to me then I'll but I gave
you reasons and it almost seems like
this one's like taking advantage of how
much I do for him I don't think he's
taking advantage of that he loves me you
know okay like let's not forget that
part
I'm glad Jamal said okay because people
love people and hurt them all the time
him loving you is nice but it's not a
huge deal you're lovable I had to learn
that myself I would get caught up in oh
he feels this way about me or oh he said
this sweet thing but then I had to
realize of course he has feelings for me
I'm a cool person I treat you right I'm
always there for you I speak life into
you and we have fun in all types of ways
was that too much Mom my mom's watching
oh Mom I'm an adult I turn 30 next year
you'll be okay but I say all that to say
I had to realize that just because
someone feels a certain way about me
doesn't mean that I have to accept their
BS
sometimes you have to affirm to yourself
it is a normal experience for people to
like me it is a normal experience for
people to love me and regardless of how
a person feels about me I still need to
ask myself do I like them and what
they're offering I don't think it's wise
to get overly excited that someone who
you're interested in is interested in
you so much so that you neglect what you
need and what would make you happy as if
they are more worthy than you because
news flash they're not
they're not I do understand why Jamal is
like you know giving me like
discouraging reasons for me to adopt
this job I mean he's my only son you
know I get it but on the other hand
Usman wants to have children and Usman
will make a great father but we have to
be on the same page I really feel like
Usman really needs to like start
explaining things more because we're
supposed to be partners in everything
you know so
my mind is not made up yet as of now you
know and I need to hear from Muhammad
and his wife again I need to hear like
is it okay I need to know their decision
but so I can make up mine so I'm
confused is she going to convert
oh
Kim is blinded by love right now but
next week it looks like things are about
to change
I'm sitting here thinking about adopting
a baby you're on your phone all the time
you don't even you can't even hold a
conversation with me we don't even have
sex
if you don't understand why you're here
then you can break your teeth and go
back
I'm done here
[Music]
the question is is she really all right
90 day fans fam make sure you stick with
ET because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
[Music]